parmi les professions très mobilisés
contre cette réforme des retraites il y
a les avocats nous recevons pierre deval
avocat au barreau de paris bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est un mouvement de colère
inédit dans votre profession septième
semaine de grève grève totale des
désignations pour les commissions
d'office et ce jusqu'au 19 février
de nombreuses nouvelles actions aux
sociétés voté il ya quelques jours comme
des attaques en responsabilité contre
les d'état pour des détails de procédure
ou bien encore le renforcement des
actions de défense massif ce sont ces
opérations ou les avocats viennent en
nombre près d un même dossier
la mobilisation donc se poursuit
la mobilisation se poursuit je vous
avais dit enfin pas à vous
personnellement mais sur ce plateau
il ya quelques semaines que les avocats
ne bougerait pas d'un iota non seulement
les avocats ne bougeront pas d'un iota
mais ils augmenteront le niveau
d'engagement dans la lutte parce que
cette réforme ce n'est pas un compromis
ce n'est pas la part du feu c'est un
diktat qui n'est pas tolérable et il n'y
a pas d'évolution positive qui viennent
dans la continuité des conversations que
nous avons avec le gouvernement alors le
président du tribunal judiciaire de
paris ainsi que le procureur de la
république de paris ont attribué au
mouvement de contestation des avocats
une dégradation importante de l'action
judiciaire que leur répondez-vous
aujourd'hui les difficultés dans
l'administration de la justice sont
totalement indifférente et ne sont pas
liées au mouvement des avocats elles
sont bien en théorie intérêts antérieur
les personnages du justice le savent ils
s'en plaignent
les difficultés sont considérables pour
les personnels de justice les greffiers
les juges les avocats
on peut se faire une opinion personnelle
sur la grève
moi je n'ai pas de réponse systématique
je vous donne un exemple cet après midi
j'ai un dossier je vais le plaidé voilà
parce qu'il ya une dimension de
détention il ya un risque de détention
je le plaid les considérations humaines
elles doivent passer devant la politique
c'est mon pauvre ses mots c'est mon
positionnement mais je suis totalement
solidaire de du mouvement je suis engagé
aussi dans la lutte et je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cette vision qui est une
vision court termiste qui perd qui
consiste à dire ce sont les avocats qui
sont responsables des difficultés
d'administration de la justice c'est une
oeuvre
c'est une vraie erreur d'appréciation
alors cet après midi on le rappelle ans
commence l'examen en séance plénière de
ce projet de loi sur la réforme des
retraites pour répondre notamment à la
grogne des avocats les députés en
commission spéciale ont voté en faveur
d'un abattement sur les cotisations des
professions indépendantes la disposition
va évidemment devoir être confirmée dans
l'hémicycle est ce que c'est une
solution là pour mettre fin à votre
mécontentement alors je vous répondrais
clairement c'est une un pis aller
c'est une plaisanterie et tout le monde
sait que la réforme obéit à une logique
très simple et je vais vous le dire
encore une fois la façon la plus claire
qui soit c'est de supprimer l'enfance de
l'art c'est-à-dire quand on apprend son
métier
on commence avec des petites
rémunération avec des cotisations qui
doivent être à l'avenant aujourd'hui
quelles que soient les réformes
cosmétiques qui sont proposés
l'objectif c'est de multiplier par deux
les cotisations et diminuer les pensions
point à la ligne
et le gouvernement a proposé pourtant
une dérogation au système universel qui
éviterait aux avocats les plus modestes
vous venez de parler à l'instant
notamment qui commencent leur carrière
d'avocat pour l'heure perdre pour leur
éviter de voir bondir leurs cotisations
on compte qu'on comprenne mais en quoi
est ce que ça consisterait très
précisément il soit 0 gassion il faut il
faut demander ça au gouvernement je
j'ai étudié la la question c'est assez
abscons pour pas dire autre chose pour
pas dire totalement ésotérique et cette
réforme
elle n'a pas de sens elle n'a pas de
sens car le système des avocats et
j'insiste sur ce point très précis et
teksid excédentaire il est solidaire
puisque il reverse chaque année 100
millions d'euros à la collectivité
il ne coûte rien il n'y a aucune raison
de le modifier et surtout les
modifications qui sont faites sont des
modifications pour le pire
encore une fois multiplication par 2
toutes ces mesures est n'ont aucun sens
et elle ne diminue pas le risque social
considérable qui existe pour les avocats
et pour les justiciables surtout parce
que c'est pas du corporatisme
c'est aussi pour les justiciables alors
en quelques mots pour qu'on comprenne
bien aujourd'hui quelles sont vos
revendications le reste identique on a
bien compris puisque selon vous rien n'a
évolué depuis le début de votre
mouvement de protestation moi je
en quel niveau pour qu'on comprenne bien
que tvo très simplement je l'avais
appelé à la raison je persiste et signe
madame j'appelle à la raison j'en
appelle à la raison du gouvernement
c'est talleyrand qui disait tout ce qui
est excessif est insignifiant
cette mesure est excessive elle est
insignifiante
elle doit être retirée de pied en cap
stop à cette réforme
laissons ce qui fonctionne perdurer
c'est un système je le répète
excédentaire c'est un système qui permet
aux avocats d'avoir des revenus corrects
même lorsqu'ils sont dans cette ce
niveau de revenus moyens il faut
permettre au système qui fonctionne de
continuer ma revendication qui n'est pas
la mienne mais qui est celle de tout le
barreau du conseil national des barreaux
de france et de toutes nos institutions
c'est le retrait complet de cette
réforme
merci d'être venus réagir sur notre
plateau pierre deval avocat au barreau
de paris